matthew stafford the lions reportedly
have already talked to one-third of the
league about
matthew stafford now
to me this just feels like an effort
to get more people to call like you
better hurry up we're we've already
talked to 10 teams we've and that when
you think when it's when you say one
third of the league it sounds it sounds
like a bigger deal it's only 10 teams i
mean shouldn't there be more than 10
teams calling the lions about matthew
stafford this is glass two-thirds empty
to me not one-third full
yeah i agree with you mike when we start
naming the franchise quarterbacks i mean
what do you get to maybe 12 i would say
it's fewer than half the teams in the
league actually have a franchise
quarterback so absolutely if i'm one of
those teams who doesn't have a franchise
quarterback i'm at least making the call
what's it going to take what are you
asking for matthew stafford and you know
it's it it's worth a phone call at the
lease and maybe he's not the guy you
want in the end but it's worth a phone
call to at least inquire about what it
would take to get him if he's an upgrade
for you now some teams i would argue
that he's not going to be an upgrade for
even those that we don't say have a
franchise quarterback i mean we talked
about this yesterday mike this is a guy
that's only made one pro bowl we do have
questions about whether it was actually
the talent around him or how much of it
was matthew stafford can he stay on the
field there's the injury history there's
a lot of questions with matthew stafford
so if you're going to go out and get him
and trade draft picks for him you better
make sure that he's an upgrade over what
you have or what you can obtain
and the more i think about this
the the more
skeptical i am about the motivation here
i think this is the lions
grabbing a megaphone and trying to get
more people to call i think they're
stunned that it's only been 10 teams and
it could be that they're thinking there
are other teams out there that were
being deliberately coy deliberately slow
deliberately aloof
because they don't want to give up too
much and the reality is this market's
going to be driven by how many teams
come to the table
serious about trying to acquire matthew
stafford you need at least two you know
in a normal trade scenario sometimes
your best leverage is screw it we just
won't trade him
once the guy wants out and once you've
decided you're going to move on you need
two three's better four is great five
six seven eight
even even more than that but
and and and if they had ten serious
suitors right now
the great that's all we need see just
because you get a call doesn't mean
anything right somebody calls hey uh
what do you want for matthew stafford oh
you want that much click so we don't
know the substance of the calls we don't
know who initiated the calls maybe it's
new gm brad holmes calling teams and he
just made it through the first 10 on the
list maybe it's calls coming into them
this is this is a chess match
with
multiple layers and levels and the goal
is to end up getting the most you can
and when one of the guys at the center
of the chess match is talking about
biting off kneecaps i don't know how
much subtlety is going to be involved in
these negotiations
well and mike i don't know what the
lions think they are going to get from
matthew stafford but my guess is it's
going to be less than what they think
they're going to get for matthew
stafford i mean
i'm not giving up two first round draft
picks for this guy to me it's going to
have to be a fairly good deal i might
think about a first-round draft pick
if it's lower in the first round and i'm
not going to get one of those top
quarterbacks but i don't think i'm
giving up a ton for for matthew stafford
mike
yeah i agree with you and again it comes
down to slowly and gradually and
carefully cultivating a market where you
pit one against the other and the best
thing to do if you could find it and i
haven't really thought about this but if
you can find two teams in the same
division right colt's texans if the
texans move on from deshaun watson if
you can find two teams in the same
division that's the way to drive the
price up and you know i i
i think that that
this is not going to be easy for the
lions but there is a way to do it if
they play it smart there is a way to do
it to get more than maybe they should
anthony lynn by the way has been
announced as a new offensive coordinator
of the detroit lion so he is joining the
the kneecap biting brigade there with
dan campbell and company
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports